Khi học thứ chính, cuối hội khoảng 15 đa thục quang hị quyết rất bánh, trong đó đến mạnh yêu cầu sớm
nghiên cứu và banh hành khu pháp lý để trường khai thị điểm vị trường tại sản má hoa tại Việt Nam.
Theo lỗi dung nghị quyết, tại sản má hoa, bao uống các tại sản số sự dụng công nghệ má hoa
hoa khóa công nghệ số khác để tạo lập, pháp hành, lưu trữ vật chuyển rào.
Đăng phát triển nhé, sau vẫn chưa có hành lăng pháp lý sợ giảng để đu trình các hoạt động như sau dịch,
chuyển dựu quyền sử hiếu hành nghĩa vụ thời liên quán.
Vy hành khu pháp lý là yêu cầu cấp thiết nhằm vào đảng quần lý sử gió,
thuộc đầy đủy mỗi sản tạo có kìm sốt, đồng thời khai thác tiêm năng phát triển kinh tế số trong lĩnh vực tại chính công nghệ.
Cuối hội đến gỳ cơ quan chức năng cân cân chương hoàn thiện và tổ chức bận hành thi điểm tị trường tại sản má hoa theo đủ lộ chiến,
bảo đảng tính miên bệnh, hiếu khoả và an tận trong người tham gia.